Where do we find clues as to how our cancer is driven?
Is it in the initial cheek swab?
Yes.
And resulting program?
No.
Well, we're talking about the right program.
No, you won't see, we're gonna close it there.
Or do we get the info from the genetic report?
No.
So, depending on when you started with us,
we used to be very open about the causes.
We have causes, balancers, and then food drivers.
It's just when we got attacked by the AMA,
then we had to be careful with our terminology.
So we had to kind of take that terminology out
that what caused the cause and what was the drivers.
We had to be more careful with that terminology.
But I'm at a point right now.
I just don't care.
They could just slowly achieve it.
I just don't care anything.
So, when you look at diet, so when you talk about
what is how our cancer is driven, let's clarify that phrase.
So, cancer could be caused from something.
So, anything that gets inside of a cell that damages
the nucleus at the DNA, the replication cycle
in the cell goes into rapid replication.
That is the initial cause of the cancer.
And you could be moved us to find it out to help deal with that.
So, it doesn't cause the same thing in a double cell.
So, understand, even if you could magically make that
all go away, let's say if the cause that got inside the cell
that damaged the DNA that caused it to go into rapid replication.
Let's pretend it was a Michael toxic.
If you could magically remove all the Michael toxins
from your body, it still doesn't solve the problem
that the cells are still in rapid replication
because the damage was done.
But, if you get rid of that, we know that your body
is susceptible to Michael toxins as a cause of cancer.
We don't want it to cause another cancer
or cancer somewhere else.
So, it's essential in mind to find out
what that causes and deal with that.
And deal with other potential causes, other toxins,
other biotoxins.
That's why we do that testing.
We want to deal with all the core amenities.
That's why I talked about autoimmune diseases
and deal with those core amenities
that could be causes of cancer.
Secondly, a driver of cancer could be a term
that we use to what is fueling the cancer.
So, remember, a cells that are in rapid replication
are very hungry.
So, hungry cells need a fuel source.
That's why we take you off of certain things.
There is a public fuel source.
That's why I recommend.
Everybody with cancer go on a lower sugar diet
and keep it your glucose levels.
If you test them with a glucometer,
at a low range will also be helpful.
Does it mean everybody needs to go heatogenic?
Doesn't mean everybody needs to do anything specifically.
We want to test for what are fuel sources.
That can change.
So, in cheek swab testing, if that changes ice,
make that note and tell you,
stay off of this food too, you know,
change your diet, I make those changes.
So, that's all done, that is all done on the cheek swab.
So, if, you know, we always recheck that driver.
So, you know, capric requests thing.
Originally, dairy was a driver.
The diet said, no, dairy, this cheek swab,
dairy was not a drive, no.
So, I don't rephrase it.
So, if I say there's a different driver than, yes.
So, if I don't tell you again that dairy is a driver,
I only make changes on the cheek swab.
So, when I said you back in probation on the cheek swab,
it's just there are any changes.
So, stay as dairy free as possible.
But, that brings up another question.
Can I ever just relax a bit on the driver?
The answer is always, yes.
So, if you've eliminated, you know,
a main fuel source for a period of time,
is it okay to have water once in a while?
Or is it okay to put some cream in like coffee
two times a week?
The answer is yes, always has been yes.
Because you can't, you're never going to completely
eliminate the fuel source.
So, that's kind of a foul.
So, you're never going to be able to completely eliminate it.
So, and I also have always said, this is a diet.
It's not a dogma, it's not a religion.
You're not, you know, first, you're not
sitting by, you know, having some butter on your toast
or something like that.
So, just make sure it, and I will say also
that it can be dangerous to even have that thought
in your mind because that is producing anxiety.
And what does anxiety do?
But stimulant is something that a reaction
which can be the worst thing for your cancer.
And I've said over and over, you know, a hundred times
that's, a lot of times the people
that do the best amounts of cancer
and end up having the best success
and the people that are like, no, tell me what to do.
I'll do the best I can and I'll leave the results to go.
The ones that are frantic and anxious
and worried and concerned and analyzing everything
and getting, you know, having OCD issues about their cancer.
And again, the problem with that is it stimulates,
it stimulates sympathetic dominance.
It shuts down your immune system
and it's shuts down your detoxification pathways.
All those things are knockout.
So don't ever beat yourself about, you know,
oh my goodness It was the sun's birthday or something
and they'll hand a educated baby over the additional.
That's not how we're supposed to even
with spiritual things, but always spirit doesn't beat you well, but you make mistakes.
He molds you, shapes you, sometimes that's not pleasant, but he's gentle and graceful,
and merciful, and that's the way you need to be, once yourself, when it comes to you.